you know i know your feud about with
eminem it was eminem a hero to you
because yeah for sure the guy's a great
rapper does it personally pain you that
you have this
[ __ ] feud with this guy i don't feel
any type of way about it i mean i'm like
asleep in my tour bus this
[ __ ] guy drops an album with like
three songs consecutively talking about
me what the [ __ ] you think i'm gonna do
just [ __ ]
you know like roll over and go back to
sleep the [ __ ] out of here you're not
gonna help me so no
like i'm like i said what i said and
you know respect the fight that's it i
listened to what you rap
and you said hey eminem you're so
successful dude
you've got money money dog
the guy down the street has money this
bull has goddamn
wealth beyond you're saying
philosophically in your head
if i had that much money i'd be happy
what are you doing
i think i could settle this feud in
about three seconds i'm just a different
type though man i'm like i'm all about
this dude i'm all about putting my arm
around people
i'm not with like doing this to people
so i i can't relate you know like we all
like
the last thing i want to ever be is an
angry legend and you know what's so sad
in this
you two guys have more in common his
upbringing is completely
[ __ ] up your upbringing is [ __ ] up
youtube guys if you got in a room
together i i'd say listen you two
look at the similarities here drop this
[ __ ] thing already you know what i
mean i really would
maybe i'll do that maybe i'll get you
two guys i'll ambush you with eminem and
we'll have a whole love fest gonna be a
beautiful thing and i'll put it on tv
and
make a lot of money
you